[Alkış]
Merhaba ben Şule hüsrevoğlu
savunma ve enerji sektörüne hizmet veren
asminsan enerjinin
az Pilsan enerjide çalışan bir
yöneticiyim size önce Bir Aşk Hikayesi
ile
konuma başlamak istiyorum
Dilerseniz benim lise yıllarıma gidelim
lise yıllarımda
birini gördüm bir sevgilim vardı ona
aşık oldum ve o zaman
lise bitiminde Tabii bir sınav var ve
sınava gireceksiniz üniversite sınavına
gireceksiniz üniversite sınavına
birlikte girdik sevdiğim adamla
sonrasında kendisi Erciyes Üniversitesi
Elektronik mühendisliğini kazanırken Ben
İstanbul Üniversitesi matematik bölümünü
kazandım ve ben matematik ağacını bir
gençtim gerçekten Matematik çözmek benim
için bulmaca çözmekle eşdeğerdi
sonrasında
matematik bölümünü kazandım ama
İstanbul'a gidilecek Babamla birlikte
yurda gittik yurt başvurusunda bulunduk
yurda kayıt olduk İstanbul
Üniversitesi'ne kayıt oldum
sonrasında
geri döndük Kayseri'ye ama benim aklım
hala sevdiğim kişi de ben onu bırakıp
nasıl gideceğim
İstanbul'da Tamam yaşamımı devam
ettireceğim o burada olacak ama bir
ilişkiyi nasıl sürdürebilirsiniz uzakta
olurken bu gibi nedenlerden dolayı ben
babama dedim ki canım babacığım
biliyorsun ben
Tıpkı okumayı çok istiyorum Gerçekten de
hayallerimden birisi de Tıp okumaktı O
beyaz önlüğü giyeceksiniz o steteskopu
takacaksınız ve insanların hayatlarına
dokunacaksınız Bu benim için gerçekten
büyük bir hayaldi dedim ki babacığım
lütfen izin ver ben bir yıl daha
Kayseri'de durayım
çalışayım ve bir yıl sonunda Tıpkı
kazanayım Tabii o zaman diyemiyorsunuz
ki benim bir sevdiğim var
Öldüm bittim Yok oldum diyemiyorsun ısla
diye haliyle çünkü Bundan 25 yıl
öncesinden bahsediyoruz Babam bu şekilde
Kandırdım diyelim ve bir yıl boyunca ben
oturdum çalıştım çabaladım
sevdiğimle birlikte o üniversitede
okurken Ben de evde çabaladım ve tekrar
üniversite sınavına girdim üniversite
sınavına girdim 3 tane tercih yaptım bu
üç tercihimden ilki Tabii ki tıpta
ikincisi
sevdiğimin bulunduğu elektronik
mühendisliği de Erciyes Üniversitesi'nde
üçüncüyü hatırlamıyorum bile şu anda
Peki ne oldu sizce
Tıpkı kazanamadım Peki neden kazanamadım
Çünkü o zamanlar şu anda var mı o sistem
bilmiyorum emin değilim Ben İstanbul
Üniversitesi'ne girip kayıt yaptırdığım
için maalesef puanım düştü ve Tıp yerine
elektronik mühendisliğine kazandım
Tabii o zaman çok oturdum çok ağladım
Hiç unutmuyorum bir gün boyunca böyle
hüngür hüngür Gözlerim şişene kadar
ağladığımı biliyorum
sonrasında iyi ki
elektronik mühendisi olmuşum ve iyi ki
bu yolu seçmişim diye düşünüyorum Çünkü
ben şuna inanıyor inanıyorum Yani bu an
şu an bu platformda Pardon bu platformda
genç arkadaşlarımız çok olduğu için
benim düşüncem şu şekilde Kader Size
birkaç tane yol Aslında sunuyor bu
birkaç tane yoldan Siz hangi yolu tercih
ederseniz o yol şekilleniyor başka
yollara dönüşüyor yani Siz kendi
kaderinizi Aslında bir nevi kendinizi
çiziyorsunuz bu seçimlerinizle ve ben
elektronik mühendisliğini seçtim
ve bu yolda ilk adımımı attım Peki işimi
seçtim eşimi seçtim mi sizce Evet şu
anda o sevdiğim adamla evliyim ve iki
tane de çocuğum var
[Alkış]
Peki üniversiteden mezun oldum
sonrasında artık bir elektronik
mühendisiydim neler yapabileceğime
kendim görmek istiyordum neler
yapabilirim acaba nasıl Mühendislik
yapabilirim tarzında birkaç tane iş
başvurusunda bulundum Bunlardan biri bir
aile şirketi idi maalesef kurumsal
olmayan bir aile şirketi idi dediğim
gibi gençler şu anda beni izliyor ve
onlara seslenmek istiyorum kurumsal
olmayan bırakın aile şirketini hiçbir
şirkette Bence boş yere emek sarf
etmeyin kurumsallık Çünkü çok önemli hem
size tecrübe katıyor Hem sizi farklı
yönlerde
eğitmenizi sağlıyor hem de
yemeğinizin gücünü farklı şekilde
görüyorsunuz Ben daha sonra sigortasız
çalıştırmak isteyen iş yerlerinde de
bulundum çalıştım ama 2 hafta zor
dayandım sonrasında çıktım ve şu anda 18
yıldır Emek verdiğim asfilsan enerjide
yöneticiyim bu departmanda Yani bu Aspir
insan enerjide üretimden tutun kalite
ar-ge proje yöneticiliği gibi çeşitli
departmanlarda rol aldım ve şu anda
yaklaşık üçte biri kadar şirketin
çalışana sahibim yakında Tam karşımda
genel müdürüm oturuyor ama genel müdür
olacağım Buna da biliyorum
[Alkış]
Çünkü şunu biliyorum Gerçekten kadının
elinden Eğer Emek veriyorsa ve
çalışıyorsa hiçbir şey kurtulmuyor
Bunu canı gönülden inanıyorum Peki ben
kadın bir yöneticiyim ama Peki
kadınlarla çalışmak nasıl acaba iş
yerinde biraz bundan diyen vurmak
istiyorum sizlere
kadınlar
Farklı ortamlara girdiğiniz zaman eğer
bir kadın varsa bu bir toplantı olabilir
Başka bir şey olabilir o ortamın aurası
farklı oluyor
farklı bir
atmosferde Siz toplantıyı ya da
görüşmeyi gerçekleştiriyorsunuz ve en
azından o toplantıda bulan bulunan
başkaları küfretmiyor Bence bu da bir
şey
[Alkış]
evli erkeklerimiz daha iyi bilir bu
söyleyeceğimi ayrıntıcı bir yapıya
sahipler yani Hani bu
obsesif olmadığı zaman obsesi seviyede
değilse ayrıntıcılık İş yerinde de bence
oldukça
işimize yarayan bir kavram çünkü Eğer
ayrıntıcılığa sahipseniz diyelim ki bir
problem oldu onun kök nedenini en ince
ayrıntısını en ince detayına kadar
araştırıp bulup Sonrasında o sorununu
çözmek için elinizden gelen her şeyi
yapıyorsunuz Ayrıca
kadınlar daha düzenli ve titiz
çalıştığına inanıyorum ben
benim mesela kendimden örnek verecek
olursam Biraz önce bahsettim size işte
ar-ge projelerimiz var Belki de 50'ye
yakın Belki de daha fazla projelerimiz
var şu anda kendi yürüttüğümüz bu
projelerin tamamından Aslında ben
sorumluyum ve genel müdürüm ya da üst
yönetimden herhangi birisi bu projelerle
ilgili herhangi bir şey sorduğunda benim
bir fihristim var ve bu fihristi Ben
düzenli olarak her gün yeniliyorum
güncel bilgilerle Bu fihristimdeki en
son güncel bilgiyi üst yönetimi ya da
genel müdürüm ve aktarıyorum ve bu
düzenli ve titizli çalışmam ve planlı
çalışmam sayesinde oluyor biraz önce
Şafak Hanım'da bahsetti Aslında
kadınların yapısı gereği
her şeyi planlayabiliyorlar ve bu
planlamaları iş yerinde farklı
pozitif etkiler olarak size geri dönüyor
bunu da ayrıca söyleyebilirim başka bir
özellikle kadınların girişken olmaları
Bizler Saygılı ve net bir şekilde
fikirlerimizi karşımıza aktarabiliyoruz
Bence kadınların en önemli
özelliklerinden biri de bu dedim ki ben
nasıl bir yöneticiyim çalışanlarıma
Ben nasıl bir yöneticiyim Aslında
ben empati yüzeyi düzeyi yüksek bir
yönetici olduğumu çalışanlar tarafından
duydum ve kendimi düşündüğüm zaman Evet
karşındakinin yerine kendimi koyuyorum
halden almıyorum yani yöneticilerin de
genel anlamda Bence
çalışanlarına da halden anlayıcı tarzda
hareket etmeleri gerekiyor
bir de işi nasıl yaptıracağını bilmek
çok önemli Size birkaç örnek vermek
istiyorum Biz biraz önce bahsettiğim
gibi savunma ve enerji sanayinde
çalıştığımız için bazı kişisel koruyucu
malzemelerine ihtiyaç duyuyoruz
çalışanlarımızda bu mesela en sevdiği
kıyafet yani elektronik statikle şarja
korumalı kıyafetler ya da
lehim dumanını filtreler tarzında
koruyucu ekipmanlar olabilir Eğer bu
Ekipmanları kullananlar bu kullandıkları
ekipmanları kullanmak istemiyorlarsa
ikna ediyorlarsa bunlardan
Siz şöyle bir şey söylerseniz Eğer
otomatik kullanılabiliyor bu lehim
dumanı sizi
derseniz otomatik halloluyor Hatta
ekstra filtreler
isteyebiliyorlar Yani işi nasıl
yaptıracağını da bilmek gerekiyor
Aslında benim çok sevdiğim bir hikaye
var bu hikayeyi de sizlerle paylaşmak
istiyorum
yaşlı bir çift
bir lisenin karşısında artık
emekliliklerinin tadını çıkartmak
istiyorlar ve bir ev satın alıyorlar bu
Yaşlı çift
gel zaman git zaman oldukça iyi vakit
geçirdiklerini
sessiz sakin bir ortamda olduklarına
düşünürken
lise açılıyor ve lise gençleri
gürültüyle işte bağırarak çağırarak yol
boyunca ki çöp bidonlarına durmadan
tekmeliyorlar bir bakıyorlar ki Yaşlı
çift Her gün aynı gürültünün
içerisindeler
ve işte okul müdürü ile görüşüyorlar
Polise haber veriyorlar ama hiçbir
şekilde Bu ses bu gürültü gitmiyor sonra
yaşlı amcanın adına bir aklına bir fikir
geliyor yaşlı amca çocukların yanına
gidiyor ve diyor ki
siz Harikasınız gerçekten Çünkü ben
gençliğimde aynı sizler gibi bu şekilde
gürültü yapıyordum ve siz bana
gençliğimi hatırlattınız
Bu yüzden bunun ödülsüz kalmaması
gerektiğini düşünüyorum ve size bunu
yaptığıma 20 TL vereceğim diyor
çocukların canına minnet bedava
yaptıkları bir işi paralı olarak
manevesiyle diyorlar ki Tamam amca biz
bundan sonra gürültü çıkartmaya çöp
fidanlarının devirmeye devam edeceğiz
sonrasında
aradan zaman geçiyor sonra yaşlı amca
bunların yanına geliyor diyor ki biz
emekli bir çiftiz
ve enflasyon oranları oldukça yükseldi
Bu yüzden size 10 TL verebileceğiz
Tabii bu arada ele başları olduğu
Anlaşılan iki genç hararetli
tartışıyorlar diyorlar ki
Tamam 10 TL'ye de fetis yani yapacak
başka bir şey yok 10 TL'yi de bu işi
yapmaya devam edeceğiz yine aradan zaman
geçiyor sonra bu zaman
geçtikten sonra belli bir yemekleri
geçtikten sonra Yaşlanınca yine
karşılarına çıkıyor ve diyor ki üzgünüm
Gençler bu ayda oran beklediğimden çok
daha yüksek çıktı bu nedenle sizlere 5
TL verebileceğim
O iki tane genç yine tartışmaya
başlıyorlar devam ediyorlar ve sonra
amcanın yanına geliyorlar 5 TL'ye Bu işi
yapacak başka hiç kimseyi bulamazsınız
Biz işi bırakıyoruz bu parayı yapamayız
diyorlar ve sonra harika bir sessizlik
işte bu
Yani bir kişiye Ne söylediğiniz değil
Bunu nasıl söylediğiniz hangi zamanda
nasıl ne şekilde söylediğini önemli
bu yine yönetici ve çalışan arasındaki
ilişkileri de böyle üst yönetici ile
altındaki çalışan arasında da böyle Neyi
ne zaman nasıl zamanı özellikle Bence
zaman yine çok önemli nasıl söylediğiniz
çok önemli yine gençlere başka bir
tavsiyem olarak bunu söyleyebilirim Peki
başka bir de dengeli samimiyet kurmak
çalışanlarımın Ben ailelerine
çığlıklarına çocuklarına Hatta
resimlerini
hastalıklarını başka her türlü durumunu
bilirim sorarım Tabii ki herkes bundan
bu hoşnut olmayabilir
bazıları hiçbir şey söylemeden
çocuklarını resimlerini bana gösterir
Hatta odama gelirler bana özel
durumlarıyla Ya da aile durumlarıyla
ilgili bana bilgi verirler Bu benim
gayet hoşuma gidiyor çünkü ben
açık olarak tutuyorum kapımı herkese
açık benim A'dan Z'ye
onlar gelirler bana anlatırlar ve
dengeli bir samimiyet kurarım onlarla Bu
da yine benim
kadın yöneticilerde gördüğüm ve kendimde
de gördüğüm güzel bir özellik
Peki son olarak ne söyleyebilirim son
olarak yine bu kamuoyu araştırmalarından
çıkararak şeffaf bir yöneticiyim ben bu
şeffaflık Bana şimdiye kadar çok şey
kazandırdı bundan sonra da
kazandıracağını düşünüyorum Ne tip
şeyler kazandırdı hesap verilebilirliği
ve benim üstlerime karşı hesap
verilebilirliği kazandırdı insanlar
korkmadan Bana hata yaparlarsa
hatalarını gelip anlatabiliyorlar
ve bu hatalar Eğer
çok Zaman geçmemişse Ki genellikle çok
şükür geçmiyor Biz gerekli önlemleri
alabiliyoruz Bu yüzden şeffaf olmak
sadece çalışanla yönetici arasında değil
her ortamda bence gerekli
son olarak sözümü Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ün bir sözüyle tamamlamak
istiyorum
milletimiz güçlü bir millet olma yönünde
azmetmiştir bunun gereklerinden biri de
kadınlarımızın her konuda yükselmelerini
sağlamaktır teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]